[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام لماذا ما زال
الرئيس العراقي الراحل صدام حسين بعد 20
عاما على الغزو الامريكيه للعراق
يحظى بشعبيه كبرى في الشارع العربي الا
يترحم الكثيرون على صدام بينما يلعنون
بقيه الزعماء لماذا لا يتذكر العرب في
العصر الحالي سوى جمال عبد الناصر وصدام
حسين بينما لا يحظى بقيه الحكام العرب باي
ذكر او اهتمام لدى الشارع الم تكن ايام
حكم صدام عصرا ذهبيا بالمقارنه مع اليوم
هل كان ليحدث للمنتقى ما يحدث الان لو كان
صدام حيه لماذا قضت اسرائيل وامريكا على
حزب البعث العراقي واعدمت رئيسه بينما
تحميانه حزب البعث السوريه ورئيسه بكل
الطرق والوسائل رغم انه دمر سوريا وشرد
شعبها
لكن في المقابل الا يمكن ان يكون الشارع
العربي مخدوعا هل يستحق صدام هذه الهاله
فعلا لماذا ما زال العرب يقدسون الطغاه
الذين بعثوا قتلا واجراما في بلادهم
وشعوبهم اليس نظام صدام مسؤولا عن جلب
الغزاه والمحتلين الى المنطقه بعد غزوه
للكويت من الذي فتح ما يسمى بالبوابه
الشرقيه امام الاجتياح الايراني للمنطقه
العربيه من الذي ركب راسه ووقع في الفخاخ
الامريكيه اليس كل ما يحدث للعرب اليوم
سببه النظام العراقي المخلوع هل كان صدام
فعلا قائدا قوميا عربيا ام اداه امريكيه
كبقيه الطواغيت العرب
اسئله اطرحها على الاعلاميه العراقي سرمد
عبد الكريم وعلى الدكتور محمد هنيد
الاستاذ في جامعه السوربون
نبدا نقاش بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
الجميع الذين يتحدثون عنه النقطه الثانيه
هي ان نحن اليوم لسنا هنا لنحفر قبور او
نشمت في الرجل كما قال حتى متابعوك على
على تويتر نحن هنا بصدد تفكيك حاله هامه
جدا تفكيكها يؤدي الى كسر دوره الاستبداد
والاحتلال وسنبين ذلك على الحلقه النقطه
الثالثه الاساسيه الملايين التي تعشق صدام
حسين هي ملايين صادقه هي ليست ملايين
كاذبه هم فعلا يحبونه مثل ما كنا نحن نحب
لكنهم لا يعرفون ماذا وراء هذه الهاله
ماذا يخفي هذا الصنم وماذا انجز الصنم
الصنم نعم هو الصنم اكيد مثل بقيه الاصنام
يعني مثل صدام حسين مثل عبد الناصر مثل
القذافي لكن يختلفون فقط في حاله التوحش
وفي القدره على القتل الان سنرى ان هناك
ثلاث عناصر اساسيه في الشارع العربي الى
تبعنا عنوان الحلقه هناك صوره صدام حسين
الشارع العربي الذي يحتفل بهذه الصوره ثم
هناك جسد وسيط لا نتحدث عنه صدام حسين افض
فما قدموا وهو بين يديه ربه يعني سواء
ترحمنا او شمتنا فيه لن نغير الامر
الجماهير العربيه تعيش واقع هو اسوا واقع
في تاريخ الامه العربيه على الاطلاق الجسد
الوسيط في الوصف هو من يتاجر بصوره صدام
حسين من يقتاك بصوره صدام حسين صدام حسين
لو نرى ما انجازه او الاساطير التي اسست
هو حامل بوابه الشرقيه للامه ايران من سلم
العراق لايران غباء صدام حسين هو حامي
حماه السنه من فتح المذابح الابوابه لقتل
السنه غير صدام حسين ومن غزل الكويت حيث
اهل السنه غير صدام حسين
هناك مقولات اخرى يعني كيفيه صدام حسين
الزعيم صدام حسين بطل صدام حسين رجل لكنها
مقولات لا تؤتي شيئا يعني لو سالنا الناس
الذين يدافعون اليوم عن صدام حسين ماذا
تقول لملايين العراقيين مليون عراقي الذين
قتلوا فقط في الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه
وماذا عنجز لو نسالهم لو تسال الاطفال في
الفلوجه اليوم التي يولد ابنائها مشوهين
بسبب الفسفور المنظر ماذا تقول لهم ماذا
تقول لضحايا ملجا العامليه الذين قتلوا
ماذا تقول لالاف العراقيين الذين يتموا
ماذا تقول الاتراك الذين الاكراد الذين
قصوا بالكيماوي هؤلاء جميعا ماذا تقول لهم
تقول لهم صدام بطل صدام زعيم الامه لماذا
الشعوب العربيه تتحب تبحث وتمجد صوره صدام
لاننا كشعوب عربيه نعيش حاله من الهزيمه
الحضريه حاله يوتم حضاري نحن ايتام اليوم
نبحث عن اي انتصار اخر انتصار حققناه هو
انتصار المغرب في كاس العالم ورايت
كيتشنفجر نبحث عن اي نوع من انواع
الانتصارات هذا العربي اكتشف شيء معين
وكلها اساطير اكاذيب عندما تقول للشعوب
العربيه من كان يعبد محمدا فان محمدا قد
مات وما كان يعبد الله فان الله حي لا
يموت صدام حسين انت ولم يجلب غير الخراب
مثله مثل عبد الناصر مثله مثل القذافي مثل
مثل بشار مثل كل الطغاه العرب ان اردنا
نحن ان نحرر المنطقه من الاستبداد
والاحتلال فلابد ان نحرر اول شيء من
الاصنام ان نفكك الحالات الاسطوريه هاته
عندما نفك هذه الحاله الاسطوريه وتفهم
الشعوب العربيه لماذا تسعى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه واكد لك ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اليوم تسعى الى بعث
اسطوره صدام حسين لماذا ذبحوه لماذا ذبحوه
يوم الفجر صباحا لكي يكتمل الدراما لان ما
اختلفت صوره يعني اسطوره صدام حسين
اختلافها عن اسطوره عبد الناصر هو ان
المخرج في اسطوره صدام حسين كان مبدعا حتى
اللحظه الاخيره وهي لحظه انتهاء الفيلم
عندما عدموه يوم الفجر يوم العيد لكي
يواجهوا رسالتين الرساله الاولى هي رساله
اهانه للامه العربيه لكي ينكدوا عليها هذا
العيب ثم الرساله الثانيه ليبقى صنم مرتبط
باقدس مقدسات الاعياد عند العرب فيتذكره
الجميع اصبح شهيد الفجر شهيد العيد فعندها
يمكن احياء هذا الصنم للاشتغال عليه مره
اخرى
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحقيقه الكلام
اللي يقوله الدكتور محمد محمد يعني غريب
عجيب اولا الشعوب لا يمكن تخدع ابدا شعوب
شعوب وخصوصا الشعوب العربيه شعوب حيه
تاريخها يمتد الى الاف السنوات انا بدي
اوضح نقطه في البدايه التاريخ يجب ان
يتوقف عند بعض الاسماء لا يستطيع التاريخ
ان يتجاوز حلو عمر المختار جمال عبد
الناصر صدام حسين التاريخ يقف مجبرا امام
هذا الاسماء يعني اللي اللي اعدم عمر
المختار يعرفوه الناس ما حد يعرفها بس كل
تعرف عمر المختار القائد الايطالي اللي
اعدم عمر المختار ما حد يعرفه رئيس
الحكومه
لكن عمر المختار خالد غصبا على التاريخ
جمال عبد الناصر الذي مصر في عهده كانت
تصنع السيارات وتصنع الثلاجات والغسالات
الجامعات المصريه ترسل الاف الاساتذه الى
الدول العربيه لتعلمها وتنقذها من ظل جمال
عبد الناصر صورته حيه وعندما استقال في
نقشه 67 من خرجت خرج الشعب العربي من من
طنجه في المغرب الى العراق ترفض هذه
الاستقاله نفس الشيء صدام حسين صدام حسين
لم يكن شخصا عراقيا انسانا عراقيا هذا
الرجل انسان عروبي بكل معنى الكلمه رجلا
بامه وهو رجل امه في رجل يعني الامه
العربيه موجوده في هذا الرجل في كل
تصرفاته يعني لا يمثل ولا يذجل ابدا وهو
فعلا كان هذا الرجل السند الحقيقي والحائط
الذي سد ايران يعني سيدنا عمر بن الخطاب
رضي الله عنه قال يا ليت لدينا بين العراق
وايران جبل من نار حتى نخلص من هذا
الموضوع الذي منع هذا المد الصفوي باتجاه
الدول العربيه صدام حسين لا توجد دفاع عن
امه بدون بدون ضحاي يعني ضحايا موجودين في
كل التاريخ والناس تموت يعني صدام حسين هل
هو ميت الان لا هو حي بين كل الجماهير
العربيه انا اتحدى يعني خلي واحد يروح
اليوم ويجيب كلمه على صدام حسين شوف شلون
تنقض الناس عليه يعني موريتانيا عند العرب
ما كانوا يعرفون موريتانيا يعني الى وقت
قريب لكن بالحرب الموريتانيه مع السنغال
كان صدام حسين رجل واقف في موقف رغم كل
الدول العربيه تخلت عن موريتانيا لانه كان
هناك قضيه حق وساعد في بناء الاعلام
والتلفزيون الموريتاني وغيرها من انجازات
مثل كل الدول العربيه انا انتقل نقطه
الدكتور قبل قليل بانه هذا صنف هذا مو صنم
صدام حسين عايش مع كان ابسط
الشرائح الاجتماعيه سواء في العراق قبل
الوطن العربي عندما كان لاجئ في مصر من
كانوا زملاء صدام حسين ورفاقه كانوا الناس
اللي يشتغلون العمال عمال المقاهي عمال
المطاعم من كان موجود في مصر هذه فتره
طويله كانت هذه الشريحه هي اللي تعامل
معاه ذلك هو يعرف تفاصيل دقيقه عن حياه
المواطن المعدوم العربي الفقير الذي لا
يملك لا حول ولا قوه لهذا يتعاطف معه
المواطن ولذلك المواطن العربي عندما تذكر
اسم صدام يتذكر الصوره الحقيقيه التي تقدم
بها صدام صدام ليس رجل حرب صدام رجل سلام
لكن بالحقيقه فرضت عليه الحرب فرضا عندما
تهاوى اسعار النفط واصبحت برميل النفط 4
دولار كلفت استخراج اكثر من قيمه النفط
وهذه كانت رد على الحرف الايرانيه
العراقيه يعني مجبور الرجل ان يتقدم لحل
هذا الموضوع لكن هنالك كانت مؤامره كديبه
انا اسال من الذي قتل صدام حسين او اعدامه
اغتاله حقيقه امريكا بايدي ايرانيه هي
التي اغتار صدام حسين ولذلك الصوره الان
عند المواطن العربي هو شهيد مثل عمر
المختار مثل كل الابطال اللي شهيد فعلا
شهيد هي ليست تمثيريه يعني هل هل صدم صدام
حسين يهرب من الواقع المرير اللي عاش
اثناء الاحتلال كان ما يستطيع عرضت عليه
يعني الشيخ الله يرحمه ارسل له مندوب حتى
يطلع هو وعائلته
قطر وزير خارجيه قطر راح برساله من الشيخ
حمد امير قطر السابق لكنه حقيقه قال لك
انا اموت مع شعبي ما ترك العراق وظل وهذه
الصوره التي
الفها الامريكان بانه طلعوه من القبو يعني
في التمثيليه حقيقه رخيصه لكن لو كان صدام
حسين شامخ الى اخر دقيقه واقف امام
الاعدام وبينه وبين الموت لحظات ولكن
مواطن العربي يعرف صدق هذه المشاعر العرب
مو يعني مو ناس يعني عاديين يعني
عندك في البرنامج هذا الاعلامي الاسرائيلي
ماذا قال عن صدام قال صدام حاكم سوريا كان
دمر اسرائيل كان دمر تل ابيب لكنه حافظ
الاسد بشار الاسد احنا اصدقاء واعدنا
علاقات ممتازه مع هذا النظام ونحن كنا
نتمتع يعني بامكانك تقارن ماذا فعلت
امريكا واسرائيل مع حزب البعث العراقي
والسوري عزب البعث العراقي ان هو وانهو
رئيس الشهد بينما جلبوا كل الغزاه العالم
كي يحموا حزب البعث السوق الشهاده يعني
شهاده البراءه من هذا الكلام تفضل بدكتور
محمد هي اعدامه من قبل امريكا من بوش صغير
يعني امريكا
هي التي جلبت ايران الى داخل العراق ودخلت
الاحزاب الميليشيات
من يقول لو صدام حاكم سوريا كان دمر
اسرائيل وصدام مو بس كلام ضرب اسرائيل
باثنين واربعين صاروخ رغم تاثير
العسكري لهذه السواري كان محدود لكن
الصيغه المعنويه كانت هائله ولذلك اسرائيل
من يقول لي واحد اسرائيل ضد ايران
واسرائيل ضد سوريا هذه خلينا بنفس الموضوع
دكتور كيف ترد
المعطيات التي ذكرها الاستاذنا الفاضل هي
هي معطيات شخصيه لكن الخطوره فيما يقوله
هو انه قفز على ملايين الضحايا العراقي
النظام البعثي العراقي نظام صدام حسين هو
نظام قاتل مجرم سفاح لا يعترف بمعارض ولا
يعترف بمعادي لعيان لا يعترف اما انت معي
او انت خائن هذه النقطه الاولى قضيه انه
كان معادي لامريكا هذه اكذوبها من قدم
الاسلحه لصدام حسين عندما كان يقاتل ايران
امريكا كانت تقدم الاسلحه
ومن قدم له حتى من قدم
النظام الايراني الموجود في العراق
الخبيثه له قدمها له الامريكان هو لا
يصنعها
استاذنا اعطيك ادله يمكن ان تعود اليه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كانت تريد
انهاك المنطقه لان العقيده الامريكيه
تحولت من ان تنيب وكيل في المنطقه اللي
كان فيها ايران بعد ثوره الخميني انها
تحظر يعني العسكريه وهذا ما فعلته طوال
ثلاثين سنه فكانت تحتاج الى عنصرين
طائفيين يتقاتل يستنزف ثروات بعضهم البعض
فتحقق هذه الشرعيه لكي تدخل وكانت ايران
جيد لو تتذكر تسلح هذا الطرف وتسلح الطرف
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كانت تدعم
ايرا وهي التي ساعدته على استرجاع الفار
كانت تقدم له الاسلحه وخاصه الاقمار
الصناعيه صور الاقمار الصناعيه تجد ذلك
موثقا في مقاله امريكيه ومقاله عراقيه اذا
كانت تبحث عن هذا عندما انتهت دور العراقي
في استنزاف
الايران
طلبوا من دول الخليج طبعا انهم يزازلوا
سقف سعر النفط لكي ينقضوا عليه فالغباء
غباء صدام حسين واستبداد وهو الذي دفع انا
قلت لك استاذنا كنت احترمه واعزه واعشقه
الى اخر لحظه لست هنا يعني
مع ضحايا الفلوجه انا معاه الملايين
العراقيين الذين انا مع انا هو الذي جلب
الامريكان
استاذنا يجلبون الغزاه كل طاغيه مستبد
لابد ان يجلب كما حدث في سوريا ادورت
الاحتلال والاستبداد هي دوره واحده لاحظ
ان كل مستبد عندما يخرج يجلب الغزاه وهكذا
الدوله عندما خرج القذافي او مات القذافي
جلب النيتو هذه معادله طبيعيه دائما يخرج
المستبد ياتي المحتل صدام حسين لم يكن
رجلا سياسيا ليبني عراق الحضاره عراق
التنوع العراقي الاختلاف عراق الكفاءات
عراق حريه الاعلام كان عراق الزعيم والبطل
الذي لا يرى الا هو يعني كان كل شيء في
صنم واحد هو صدام حسين من كان مع صدام
يعيش ويصعد ومن كان ضد صدام يموت مهما كان
اختلافه معه اذا نحن في تفكيك حاله
استبداديه وليس ضد هذا الرجل في شخصه ماذا
اقول انا لملايين العائلات العراقيه قتلت
نقول له والله لاجل عيون صدام لانه
هل لاجل عيون العراق عراق الحضاره
والتاريخ تحولت الى 200 او 300 سنه كل
امكانيات العراق الفلاحيه والمائيه
والذهاب والنفط والخام ذهب اليوم لكي بسبب
صدام يعني بسبب غباء صدام حسين معقول يا
رجل نعم
من كان من كان يتحدث عن المدفع العملاق من
كان يتحدث عن رابع جيش في العالم قال احد
الدبلوماسيين العرب واحد وهات الدبلوماسيه
العربيه كان رجلا قابلا للنفخ كان يقبل ان
ينتفخ فنفخت فيه الاعلام الغربي كان ينفخ
فيه مثل ما نفخ في طالبان قبل ان ينقض
عليهم كانوا قابلين لذلك هو قبل تلك
الوهره وكانت الجماهير العربيه ساهل
الجماهير العربيه الساهمت في تدمير العراق
لانها صفقت لصدام حسين وقالت له انت
جماهير العربيه نعم الجماهير العربيه
ساهمت في تدمير العراق الشعوب التي خرجت
ترفع شعار بالكمياوي يا صدام لتخلص في ذبح
العراق انت قصدت انت قصدت تل ابيب بعشرين
صاروخ من مفرقعه هو قصف بغداد بما يقارب
بما هو قوه اربع قنابل او خمس قنابل نوويه
الاطفال الذين ماتوا عبير عبير قاسم
الجنابي التي اغتصبها جندي عراقي وقتل امه
وابوه واخوها واغتصبوها واحرقوها من يدفع
ثمنها هاته البنت غباء صدام حسين لانه كان
مجرما طاغيه ككل الطرق انا مع تقديري ليه
انا افكك هذه الحاله لماذا لكي نمنع اعاده
انتاج صدام حسين اخر لان هذه الشعوب تعشق
صناعه الطغاه تعشق صناعه الاصنام نحن
دورنا هو ان نصعد جيل لا يعشق صده ولا
يعشق بشار ولا يعشق عبد الناصر ولا
القذافي هو جيل وشعب يؤمن بالمؤسسات
القانون فصل السلطات حريه التعبير حريه لا
تصنع لي بطل وتقول لي هذا والله يا اهلها
الاصنام ماتت يا اخي صدام حسين افضى الى
ما قدم هو امام محكمه التاريخ انا احكم
بالنتائج اين العراق اليوم العراق اين
العراق اين العراق اليوم العراق اليوم هو
ذيل من ذيول ايران طيب هو بسبب صدام صدام
حسين طبعا صدام حسين كان مستعد انه يبيع
يبيع العراق لكي يبقى
لان اقول لك بوركيبه قال يقول الناس لا
تعرف تونس تعرف بورقيبه القذافي قال لك
انا ليبيا هذا صدام يقول لك انا العراق
القذافي يقول لك انا ليبيا هؤلاء يقتصرون
الوطن ثم بعدهم ماذا يحدث الخراب والدمار
والفناء للشعوب كلام غريب يعني كلام غريب
جدا
العراق بزمن صدام حسين بنى قاعده علميه
متقدمه جدا الاف البعثات الى دول اوروبا
وامريكا والغرب واتحاد السوفيتي السابق
وروسيا حلو اساتذه الاف الاساتذه والدرجات
موجودين كلهم هذه الدرجات العلميه خلقت
تقول لي تعالى الكيمياوي او على
البيولوجي يعني استوردها من امريكا العراق
صنع انا ضابط الجيش العراقي انا كنت ضابط
الجيش العراقي صنع الصواريخ الباليستيه
كانت تجرب من الرطبه وتقع في الناصريه
بخطا
لا يتجاوز خمسه امتار عن الهدف هذا العراق
عراق علمي عراق بلد العراق بلد الحضارات
لا هو صدام اللي خلق هذه حاله مجانيه
التعليم يا دكتور والزاميه التعليم
بالعراق من الابتدائي
في العالم الثالث صدام خلق قاعده علميه
وحذر فقط على العرب يعني يدخلون في ميدان
التدريس لا يجوز لاجنبي يدخل تدريس عدد
جامعا عربي من حقه يدرس لانه التعليم مهمه
الدوله وليس مهمه الشركات لانشاء مدارس
خاصه وجامعات خاصه هذه مهمه الدوله ولذلك
كان العراق يتصدى ناسيه العلم وهذا اللي
ازعج امريكا حقيقه لان وصل الى درجه متقدم
يعني يعني العراق الجرثومي انطوه من
امريكا امريكا حضرت على العراق حتى قلم
الرصاص صحيح حاصره العراق قلم الرصاص لن
يخافون من العراقي
كثيره بالنسبه الى الحلف اللي يتكلم الان
بانه ايران ضد اسرائيل
لانه الحرب يعني حتى تعرف الوقائع الحرب
الايرانيه العراقيه اللي صارت طائرات
الفانتوم عجلات الاحتياط التي الفانتوم
الامريكيه كانت اسرائيل تزود ايران فيها
هذا قال الدكتور
اسرائيل يعني اسرائيل ليست انا اسرائيل
ليست نيد لايران ولا ندوري
الموضوع اللي بانه هذه القاعده اليوم
ناخذ الكاميرا مال الجزيره ونروح لاي قريه
عربيه
يعني اي قريب انا اتحدى انا اسال الجزيره
خل ناخذ كاميرا ونروح بشخصيات غير معروفه
ونسال عن صدام حسين في قريه بعيده غير
متعلمه في المغرب في تونس في الجزائر في
اي بلد في الخرطوم في اليمن اسال عن صدام
حسين الحرب التي فرضت على العراق لايصال
لايصال هذه العنصريه الطائفيه صدام ليس
سنيا وما غزل الكويت لانه سني الكويت نسخه
شيعه وهذا هذا التالف موجود انا عراقي
وضاب ط بالجيش وانت شيعي
دخلت الى الجامعه ما اعرف زميلي شيعي او
سني ما اعرفه يعني هذه صارت بعد ما صارت
صحيح
الامريكا دخلت الى العراق بغرض تدمير
القاعده العلميه
من صدام اعطاني
لا صدام حسين
بهذا الرجل شهيد عربي وسينتفضون كل العالم
كيف تقول صدام صدام حسين غبي صدام مو غد
صدام حسين كان رجل
ملايير
كم جزائري استشهد تحررون الجزائر
اركب لك في تاكسي في المغرب
وجيب سيره صدام حسين
يقول لك ما تدفع ما تدفع لو كان المشوار
هم ناس على قد حالهم وما يقبل يعتبر اهانه
اذا تدفع فلوس التاكسي روح لاي مكان هذا
ما اجى من بلاش الوطن العربي شعب العربي
احنا ما نقول انا والدي الليله سينكرني
لاني تهجمت على صدام حسين اقول لك لا تقول
لي
هذا الكلام فرض على فرض على العراق بعد
العدوان الثلاثيني كم 30 دوله تحالفه ضد
العراق كم وسيط جاء لصدام قال له والله
يرحم والديك خذ اموالك وغادر العراق
لندمره ليش هو يدور مال هو صدام حسين
اذا اكو سنتيمتر واحد باسم صدام حسين
بالعراق القصور اللي بناها للشعب هي قصور
الشعب هذولا اخذوها اللي اجوا من ايران
باسمائهم اتحداك اذا صدام حسين يملك مئه
دولار اذا صدام حسين عنده غرام ذهب صدام
حسين يعتبر الوطن العربي كله ملكه يعتبر
في طنجه في الخرطوم في القاهره وين ما
يروح صدام صدام وين يروح دكتور من يعمل
جولاته في داخل العراق وداخل المنطقه يروح
على البيوت الفقراء يروح الى المطبخ يفتح
الطنجره مال الطبخ ويشوف شكو اكل عندهم
بالثلاجه اكل اليوم اليوم في لبنان يعني
احد الصحفيين العرب المع يقول في في
برنامج بانه ذهب الى بيروت وقاعد في مطعم
ياكل بيه باستمرار اعتذرت صاحب مطعم قال
له ما اقدر والله قال له ليش ماكو خبز ما
في خبز بيروت ما في خبز تدري انت صدام
حسين
اثناء الحكومه المؤقته اللي شكلها جميل
شكلها برئاسه ميشيل عون جنرال في وقتها
وكانت حكومه اخرى ابرزه تلحس منفصل وكانت
الحكومه الاخرى مدعومه من سوريا ارسل
رساله الى صدام قال له احنا الجيش الجيش
اللبناني الان منقسم وما عندنا رواتب ارسل
له ثلاثين مليون دولار احنا المشكله في
هذه الطبقه لا تقول
هل نختلف في محمد مرسي انه رجل فاضل طيب
وكذا وكان نختلف فيه محمد مرسي رجل طيب
فاضل كذا كذا كل ما تريد ممكن يعطيك لا لا
اين اوصل محل نجح في يعني تحقيق انتقال
ديمقراطي بمصر ومحارب
شوف غلطه الشاطر بالف انا لا يمكن ان
اتحمل قياده دوله يمكن ان يؤدي بها الى
الخراب وقلهم والله انا رجل شاهد يا اخي
شهم شامل
محمد
بالله انت لو تروح الفنلندا وانت تسكن في
الغرب لو جيت قول لهم والله الوزير
الفلاني رجل طيب
هل انجز ماذا انجز بالنسبه للتضخم ماذا
فعل في المجال هذا ماذا فعلت نحن مجتمعات
والديمقراطيه لا تقول لي يا مولانا
مجتمعات مغربيه ديمقراطيه والدليل انك
تعيش فيها وانا اعيش فيها
صدام حسين صدام حسين مهما كانت فضائله
الشخصيه انا على رجال من موضوعي النتيجه
عندي العبره بالنتائج اين العراق الحضاره
لحظه
واوصل ناصيه العلم
العراقي موجود العراق موجود قبل صدام حسين
الله يبارك فيك وانت وانا نعلم كيف وصل
صدام حسين الحكم بالانقلابات دور
المخابرات الامريكيه
يعني ليس لم يكن زعيما قوميا زعيم القوميا
وله يحزن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تقضي علي
فتقضي عليه محمد بوضياف عندما اراد اصلاح
الجزائر وارادوا قتله قتلوه على الشاشات
عندما يريدون يتخلص من اي زعيم يتخلصوا
لكن هناك اصنام اصنام تسعى الى تكبير
الجماهير فتبقى هذه الجماهير تحلم بالمهدي
المنتظر بالرجل بيخرج من السرداب او لا
اعرف منين ينزل من السماء تقول له يا اخي
الخلاص لن ياتيك من هذا الزعيم خلاص
سياتيك من نفسك يعني يعني انتم جماهير
عربيه لابد ان تنتقم الجماهير العربيه
لابد ان تنتخب انسان عادي مثلي ومثلك لديه
وظائف يقوم البرنامج وبعدين يروح في 60
داهيه انا لا اريد لا ابدا انت تنهي
برنامجك ثم احاسبك تسجن مثل ما يفعل
اليهود مثل يفعل الجميع الصهاينه اليوم في
اسرائيل رئيس الجمهوريه يحاسب ويدخل السجن
احنا يعبدوه احنا يولي سنه
يصلحوا الناس الذين قتلوا الناس الذين
قتلوا والله نقفز ونمسح على جثثهم ماتوا
في الكويت الاف الابرياء ماتوا جنود
عراقيين
يعني جنود عراقيين راجعين من الكويت
تذكرتي ذبحت ذبح ذبحا دمرها وبعدين يقول
لك احنا هذا الصرف انا دوري ليس صدام حسين
صدام مات قتل الاستاذ لم يفهمني صدام
تاريخه كان يمكن يكون اطيب شخص في البشري
ما يهمني ماذا خلف في العراق خلف
هذا الذي
هذا باختصار
اذا نحن بقينا في دوله الموتى دوره صناعه
الاصنام فهذه الجريمه فكريه واكاديميه
يريدون للشعوب العربيه ان تنتظر المخلص
انت تقرا على تويتر يقول لك والله كل 100
سنه سياتي واحد يجدد يا اخي محمد اخر
الرسل عليه الصلاه والسلام انتهى الموضوع
الان كبشر كجماعات ماذا تستطيع ان تفعل
لبناء دوله الرجل الذي بناه هاته الناطحات
السحافه الدوحه هذا قال لهم انا زعيم قال
انا بطل مغوار وبحرق نسخه خلي النار تاكل
نص اسرائيل قال لهم ساجعل نصف الشعوب
الكره الارضيه يتمنى عنده الجنسيه القطريه
هل كلام صحيح صحيح نصف الناس تريد ضرب لا
لانه لا يتكلم نحن نحن لا نصنع ذلك نحن
نريد زعامات نصنعها ونعبدها ونعلق عليها
كل الشماعات ما اريد اقول للاستاذ هو ما
يريد ان يفهم انا معك في الجانب الشخصي
اللي ذكرته والله
لكن والدي المسكين هذا حد علمه فنحن
القطعه هذه الضخمه في الشعوب العربيه اللي
متاثره بالعاطفه نريد ان نحولها ان نزيحها
الى جانب عقلاني فتبصر الامور باشياء اخرى
لاننا ان بقينا في هذا سنبقى في دوله
الموتى
يعني رد لي على هذه الرجل يقول لك يعني هل
نحن بحاجه لمزيد من الصدامات او من من
الصدامين اذا صح التعبير كيف كيف يحتاج
قياده انت تحتاج قياده القياده تستطيع ان
توحد الجماهير انا في هذا العصر الان اجيب
لك مثل الاردن كبلد الاردن كبلد لولا صدام
حسين في قرار القياده قياده الحزب يزودون
الاردن بنصف واحتياجاتها مجانا من النفط
لان هذا النفط مو ملكنا كل الجماهير كان
ماتت الاردن والنصف الثاني
مكان صدام حسين ما ما الى ايادي فيه ارسل
المدرسين العراقيين الى الجزائر لتعليم
الجزائريين اللغه العربيه التي يتكلم واحد
لغه عربيه يعدم بالساحات
خلي اكمل انا
هذي بناء هذه قياده قعد تبني شيء للوطن
العربي بشكل يعني تبدا تقدر انت والدك
ووالدنا كل اهلنا اذا كانوا نصيه الاميه
شو يفيد تنطيه مصاريف فندق درجه اولى اذا
ما هم متعلم ناصيه العلم المدرسين هذه
انجازات هذا بناء دوله بناء روح وين انتهى
وين انتهى المسار شو ليه تقول لي شوف لا
تقول لي بانه امريكا خلقت صدام امريكا
اغتالت صدام اغتالت صدام
انا اقول لك احنا بحاجه الى قياده احنا
المشكله الان بحاجه الى قياده يعني عمر
المختار من استشهد او او جماهير الجزائري
لا موسيقى اخر هي نمشي نفس الفكره يعني
الجزائر مليون شهيد قدمت واجا بعدين بنبله
واجى بعدين
قياده تاريخيه
لانه واجه الاحتلال
الفرنسي
صدام حسين قياده تاريخيه وطنيه عروبيه حق
انسانيه
العراق
وحالك سؤال بسيط بسيط هل لو لم يغزو صدام
حسين الكويت هل كنا وصلنا الى هنا طيب بدي
اسالك
لو لم يدخل هلق تقول لي فرضت علي الحرب من
ايران لو لم يدخل في حرب بس دقيقه مع
ايران طيب لماذا القياده الحقيقيه القياده
التي تستطيع ان تتحكم بمسار البلد
وباعصابها لا تنطلق في حروب عبثيه تقضي
على البلد يعني شوف النظام عنا القياده
البعصيه السوريه القياده يحتفظون بحق الرد
من خمسين سنه كل يومين بيدعسوا على راسه
للاسرائيلي اليوم دعسوا على راسه ماشي بس
على الاقل على الاقل لم يدخلوا بحروب غير
محسوبه يعني من الافضل ان لا تدخل بحرب
غير محسوبه على انه تعمل بطولات تودي
المنطقه العربيه البعض يقول لك كل ما
تعانيه المنطقه العربيه الجيوش التي جاءت
الى الخليج اه المنطقه استبيحت ايران دخلت
الى المنطقه كل ذلك بسبب طيش صدام حسين
كيف ترد هذا ظلم كبير
صدام حسين اولا بعد الحرب العراقيه وانا
قلت لك انا ضابط من جيش العراقي انا ضابط
بالجيش العراقي واعرف ما جرى بالحرب الحرب
لم تكن حرب بين ايران والعراق وانما كانت
الحرب بين امريكا واعوانها ضد العراق وضد
العرب لانه التهديد بغزو المنطقه كان في
زمن صدام حسين ووصلت من احتلوا راسا
الرئيس الايراني ارسل الكويت قال لهم احنا
جيرانكم عمليه تحرير وفاو شوف النماذج
اللي صارت تحرير بعمليه عسكريه فائقه
الدقه راسا ما نسى صدام حسين بانه هذا هذا
النصر هو نصر عراقي
شوف كانت في سرايا في الجيش العراقي من
سرايا المعدات الفنيه هذه مهمتها تكشف
القطعات اللي امامك يعني مثلا كانت فرقه
الحرس 77 كانت تتواجد بمنطقه معنا راح
تصير هجوم لكن كانوا يخلقون شبكات وهميه
يعني
احد الاخوان الموجودين الان في في دبي وهو
يعرف نفسه تدري يصنع العراق رادار من من
ادق الرادارات الموجوده تكشف ايراني لحدود
المدفع العملاق لانه يامن نفسه
العراق يعني يعني من حق من حق الغرب ياخذ
مدفعيه انا بدي اكمل النقطه اللي عدنان
صدام حسين ما نسب بتحرير الفاء والعرب
فسوى شارع عربي قرى عربيه شاركت فيها كل
الدول العربيه في المحرره موجوده لحد الان
الكويت الها سعودي قطر مصر لانه هذا النصر
نصر عربي والحرف حرب عربيه كان مهدد
النظام العربي لكن تعرف الانظمه بعد ما
انتهت الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه والتي قال
الخميني تجرعت السم حتى اوقع تجرات اسم
يعني صدام حسين هو لا الجيش والامه
العربيه لان الحرب لم تكن حرب عراقيه
ايرانيه وانما كانت عربيه ايرانيه والوضوء
واضح جدا انه كانت عربيه عربيه ايرانيه
لماذا لماذا بعد ذلك غزا بلدا عربيه
واستعبى كل العرب عليه والخليج تحديدا
الكويت كانت ايضا وقعت في الفخ وصلوا سعر
الدولار مال نفط اربع دولار تعرف انت
المساله هيك
وقع طبعا القياده العراقيه اعلنت يعني
والرفيق عزت الدوري النائب اعلن بانه كانت
قرار خطا وهذا ممكن يصير خطا لكن لا تقول
لي بانه الخطا صدام حسين دمر العراق صدام
حسين بلا العراق صدام حسين بنى العراق
والامه العربيه ولذلك انا اقول اليوم احنا
قاعد نتائج خطيره جدا يعني اليوم التحول
اللي قاعد في المنطقه هو تصور تحول ايجابي
انا اعتبره سلبي جدا لانه انا لا اقول لك
مع امريكا احنا امريكا العدو اللدود للعرب
وان كان الشاه وان كان الخميني خميني وين
كان عندكم باريس موجبه الطياره الفرنسيه
رجعتها
يعني جهاز هذا معروف هذا النظام النظام
ايراني بالضبط هذا النظام هو مهمته تدمير
المنطقه ماشي بس بس احنا موضوعنا صدام
حسين صدام حسين اليوم استثمر في الوطن
العربي استثمار صحيح يعني من فتح العراق
ما هي صدام حسين شركه صدام حسين اليوم روح
بالشارع عربي روح قل لصدامك تركته بانه لا
يقبل لهانه لا يقبل الظلم لا يقبل
الاستعمار لا يقبل الهيمنه في كل الشارع
العربي
صدام حسين
رجل قادم الوطن العربي قادم
صدام حسين عربي صدام حسين الى بيت الى بيت
في الخرطوم الى بيت روح اليوم شوفوا رمضان
احنا الكريم الان شوف الموائد الرحمن اللي
تمد باسم صدام حسين والمساجد التي بنيت
وكتب عليها صدام حسين روح الاردن الصادقون
اللي عملوا هذا الصادقون
هذا مو غباء انت ما تقدر تستقبل الشعوب
العربيه اشياء ماكو لو لم تكن غبيه ما كان
حالها الان هذا الشعوب العربي
هي الشعوب الوحيده
الان القياده السعوديه والقياده القطريه
وقياده الخليج بداو يكتشفون الحقيقه الان
الحقيقه بانه هذه التنميه تنميه مصطنعه
امريكا تريدها ودول ساهموا في دمار العراق
ام لا طبعا
لانهم لا يملكون حولا انا اقول لك اليوم
العراق العراق كانت بزمن صدام حسين مستقل
سيادي سد منيع ضد كل الاهواء ومن الذي ضحى
بكل ذلك اليست اعمال صدام حسين صدام حسين
شوف صدام حسين كان النقطه الاساسيه يعمل
عليها هو تحرير الفكر العربي وتحرير
القوميه العربيه
الدكتور فيصل هذا الرجل يوقفه الكاميرا
لماذا لا عبده الرجل الرجل دمر دمر
العربيه
انا انا لن يكن في الحضن الامريكي انا
ساتحدث عن تجربه شخصيه ذات يوم انا ذهبت
الى العراق ومررت عبر الحدود السوريه
التنف الى العراق وقابلت في ذلك الوقت عدي
صدام حسين فسالني كيف كانت الرحله من دمشق
الى بغداد قلت رحله ممتازه بس انا يعني لا
لا اتفهم لا افهم هذه الحدود المصطنعه بين
بين دمشق وبغداد يعني عيب يكون هذه الحدود
عيب يكون هالحدود افتحوا هذه الحدود خلي
الناس خلي
والامريكان الامريكان الامريكان طيب اذا
واحد يقول لك والامريكان يعني انه غير
مسموح لك كيف تقول لي حريه واستقلال
وسياده وكذا وهذا يقول لي انه الامريكان
لا يسمحون لنا ان نتحالف مع سوريا والعكس
صحيح
المهمه كان يتكلم عن الوضع ابن سوريا
والعراق قال انا اتحدى حافظ الاسد انا
اتحدى نجيب الدول العربيه الانتخابات
بالعراق وفي سوريا في دمشق وبغداد
القياده اللي تفوز هي تقود البلدين الوحده
ولذلك حافظ ما يقبل حافظ الاسد بانه لان
هذا تهديد وجودي له والمساله هي ليست ترى
شوف هذه الكلمه بانه هذول
من يتذكر حفظ الاسد الان ومن يتذكر صد
ام يعني المخرج كرا
ر
دراما صدام كانت رائعه صدام يعني صدام
جابوه في الفجر يوم العيد يعني طيب يعني
بس دكتور انا بدي اسالك سؤال متل ما سالته
الاستاذ طيب يعني لماذا لا نقول ان صدام
يعني كان ضحيه كان ضحيه يعني
لمشاريع وخطط اكبر من العراق واكبر من
الخليج واكبر من العالم العربي كله يعني
اذا امريكا
استطاعت ان تنصب فخا لبوتين
للرئيس الروسي بوتين يعني وهو وهو يقود
دوله عظمى ودوله امبراطوريه اذا صح
التعبير روسيا استطاعوا ان يخدعوه ويورطوه
في حرب اوكرانيا وهو سقط في
الفخ الاوكراني او في المستنقع الاوكراني
فاذا لماذا يعني لماذا لماذا نقيم الدنيا
ولا نقعدها على انه صدام وقع في الفخ صدام
مجرد وقعه في الفخ كان لديه مشاريع كان
كذا لكن القوه الكبرى تستطيع ان تورط
لاكبر منه بالف مره فما بالك صدام صحيح
كلامك صحيح لكن دكتور فيصل هل توجد دوله
او قائد في العالم ليس عليهم مؤامره
مستحيل كل دوله الصين وما ادراكم
الشاطر من هو الحكيم من هو هو الذي يؤمن
شعبه من هاته المزالق هنا الحكمه
العنتريات
يجعل النار تاكل نص اسرائيل ولا شواربك
يعني
لحظه لحظه
اني ساصنع لك فخا الفخاخ موجوده لكل دوله
لكل حاكم في العالم الحكيم هو من يتفادى
الفخاخ الى غير ذلك ويؤمن ويؤمن دماء
الناس المسؤول عليها لان كلها في رقبته
اذا كان سيد الامه قال لك هدم الكعبه حجرا
حجرا عند الله اهون من دم المسلم فما بالك
بالملايين هذه الملايين
له قيل له خذ اموالك واولادك وخذ لك مكان
في ليبيا وابقى عز احرق البلد الاسد او
نحرق البلد القذافي او نحرق ليبيا صدام او
ندمر العراق هذه القاعده عند
لا لا اللي بلا العراق هو الشعب العراقي
هو الشعب العراقي من صدام حسين لو كان في
عبد الله بن صالح اخر لا كانوا هو اللي
بناها السواعد العراقيه والعقول العراقيه
والجنود العراقيين
لا لا
انا لست كارها لصدام حسين وعدت مليون مره
كنت من عشاق لكن لابد ان نرى امام اعيننا
اثار الدماء اليوم لابد من المحاسبه
نحاسبه انفسنا
الان بوتين الان لو ادى بروسيا الى الدمار
والتفكيك سيشنقه الروس سيعلق على المجاز
خاصه انه عنده النووي انت تعادي امريكا
وطز طز في امريكا ويا صدام ليش عندك انت
ما عندك شيء فيه دمروه
تحصد منه العائلات العراقيه اللي تشحت
اليوم وما عندها
سؤال استاذ يعني البعض يقول انه
صدام يحظى بشعبيه كبرى في الشارع العربي
لكن ليس في الشارع العراقي يعني انا وصلني
اليوم على على تويتر يقولون لي يا اخي
انتم هذا سؤالك اصلا غلط انك تقول لماذا
يحظى صدام بشعبيه ربما يحظى بشعبيه عند
العرب لانه العرب لم يروا لم يروا ما فعله
صدام بالعراقيين لم يروا
اجاوبك على هالكلام انا اتحداك امام
الكاميرا
الاعداء صدام حسين في العراق اعداء صدام
كلهم يترحمون عليه يترحمون عليه ويقولون
صدام حسين كان قائد وطني كان يعرف يعرف
الخلل وين ولذلك كان يضرب من حديد على كل
من يحاول
الخطوط صدام حسين سني لو شيعي صدام حسين
لا سني ولا شيعي صدام حسين يروح من بنى
المراقد وطورها وبناها وذهبها في نص
الازمه كانت صدام حسين القياده العراقيه
كانت تروح تقسم اليمين عند المراقد
الشيعيه بين قوسين ترى هذا الكلام بانه
العراقيين هذه تويتر هذول ذيول ايران مش
دم العراق الان الشيعه في العراق وانا
اقول لك بفخر بانه بالحرب العراقيه
الايرانيه كانوا الجيش العراقي سبعين
بالمئه
والمدن التي كانت تقاتل ايران حتى كانوا
حتى المطلوبين
بقياده صدام بعد الغزو الامريكي 38 منهم
شيعه قياده واللي جاب حزب البعث للعراق
فؤاد الركابي الله يرحمها شيعي والقياده
القطريه تربح شيعه ثوره شيعه ما له علاقه
شيعه سنه بالعراق مو موجود
تصير معارك المدن الشيعيه مثل الناصريه
السماوه البصره هذه المدن الشيعيه كانت
علامات السود مال الشهداء والسيارات تنقل
للشهداء بالميات يعني لم تكن هذه
يعني مو الصوت غير نكمل
انا
يعني لم تكن هذه الصوره موجوده في تكريت
او في سامره او في الموصل المدن كانت
المدن الشيعيه هي التي تقاتل ايران وكانت
هناك بعدين الان انكشفت اللعبه الان
انكشفت
العراقيين الان هذول الشيعه يقولون
مطلوبين من صدام واعداء صدام يقول له يجي
انتخابات احنا ننتخب صدام حسين بالعشره
لانه شوف صدام حسين لا سرق ابنه
لماذا
الخطاب الاخير لبنته المداخله لان انا
اعتقد ان الامريكان واعتقد والله العقل
الام انه يعيد انتاج البعث من جديد فيبقى
العراق متناحر اما بين طائفيه قاتله تذبح
الشعب العراقي او طاغيه مستبد لا يرحم كان
قدر العراقي بعد ما قطعتها
يعني اما انا اني اضع مرجل طائفي تتقاتل
فيه مكونات الجسد العراقي الواحد سنه
وشيعه وساهم فيها صدام حسين بذبحه بقتل
المعارضه الشيعيه كلها يمكن عندما كان
منتفخ يحكم اما ان اجلب طاغيه مستبد يعني
المنوالين في المنطقه العربيه اما طاغيه
مستبده او الاحتلال ما فيش من ولا اخر اما
جيت قل لي يا شعوب
محمد سيد الامه مات ما فيش زعامه تعالوا
دوله مؤسسات اعطيني برنامج فلاحي اقتصادي
تعليمي كذا نطبقوه نحاسبوا المسؤول يوضع
في السجن من اين لك هذا ونطبق القانون
والقضاء هو الحاكم الاعلى القانون يقول لك
لا نحن نريد زعيم نريد مخلص يعني نريد
يعني ساحر يعني ياتينا المشكله في الشعوب
طبعا الشعوب
لان الشعوب العربيه لو كانت شعوب واعيه ما
كان هذا مصيرها تذبح في سوريا تجوع في مصر
في ليبيا في تونس في الجزائر اعطيني شعب
عربي واحد سعيد واحد فقط
القليله حتى اللي في الخليج موجوده هي
بسبب طفره النفط والغاز والرفاه وانظر
العماله يعني عدد السكان يفوت يعني عدد
الخدامين يفوت عدد السكان فهذه طفرها
نتمنى لهم السلامه والخير وبقاء لكن ليس
حقيقي لا توجد دوله مؤسسات لو تستطيع دوله
عربيه تبني دوله مؤسسه ببرلمان منتخب يمنع
تصور
اخطبوط كبير استبداادي كبير مثل حفتر
اليوم او بقيه الاصنام يمكن ان يؤسس
لمرحله جديده جميل جدا كلمه اخيره كلمه
اخيره بعد 20 عاما على الغزوه الامريكي
للعراق صدام هل سيبقى يعني هل سيبقى برايك
المثل المثل الاعلى للشعوب العربيه انتهى
الوقت صدام باقي الى ابد التاريخ صدام
حسين لم يموت
[موسيقى]
صدام حسين باقي انا كل المؤسسات الموجوده
بالعراق من ضمنها الحكم الذاتي مسعود
برزاني الان هو يشهد هاي مؤسسات صدام حسين
سيبقى سيبقى ويستمر وننتظر وجود قياده
عربيه حكيمه تاخذ الوطن العربي لبر الامان
كما فعل صدام طبعا كما فعل صدام نعم
يبقى لنا
الدكتور محمد هنيد وسيد سرمد عبد الكريم
نلتقي مساء ثلاثاء المقبل فحتى ذلك الحين
وفيصل القاسم يحييكم من الدوحه الى اللقاء
يعطيكم العافيه يا جماعه
[موسيقى]